let's keep doing some problems so in the
last time I said what is the chances of
what are the chances of getting not
getting any heads if I flip the coin I
was going to say dice but I realize
we're dealing with a coin if we flip the
coin seven times we said well that's the
same thing as getting seven tails in a
row and that's one-half to the seventh
power right because each trial there's
one half of getting the exact same a 1/2
chance of getting the exact thing that
we want which in this case is tails and
you multiply it times itself seven times
and you get one over 128 and actually
turns out that there are actually 1 over
128 possible results that we can get
equally probable results and why do I
say that well what's the probability
what's the probability of getting I
don't know all heads and then the last
flip I get is tails so heads heads heads
heads so I'm doing it seven times right
it's one two three four five six and
then the last time I get a tails right
well this is if you can think of it this
is exactly one particular result out of
the total results that we could get and
what's the probability of this well
there's a 1/2 chance of getting a heads
1/2 chance of a heads 1/2 chance of a
heads let me switch colors 1/2 chance of
a heads 1/2 chance of a heads 1/2 chance
of heads and then 1/2 chance of a tails
but once again this is just 1/2 times
1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 times
1/2 which is equal to 101 over 128 so
any particular I don't want to say
combination because we'll learn a little
bit about permutations and combinations
in future videos but any particular set
of circumstances we want is 1 out of 128
of the total number of outcomes that's
what I should use instead of
circumstances outcomes if I have any
particular outcome so this is a
particular outcome there the way to view
it there are 128 particular outcomes so
if I choose one of them my odds of
getting it is 1 out of 128 so let me ask
you a question what's the probability of
getting exactly
exactly one heads what's the probability
of getting exactly one ads so what does
this mean this means I could get oh I
could get tails tails tail and let's say
we're doing it let's say we're doing it
five times just so I don't waste too
much time out of five rolls out of five
flips out of five flips so that could be
tails tails heads that could be as you
can tell I switch colors arbitrarily
that could be tails tails tails head
tails all right I think you get the
pattern tails tails heads tails tails
that could be tails heads tails tails
tails I could be tails
sorry that could be heads tails tails
tails so if we look at it this way
there's there's this probability there's
actually how many events how many
outcomes would satisfy the statement
exactly one heads well there's one two
three three four five and then way you
could think of it is we're going to do
five flips exactly one of the flips is
going to be heads it could be any one of
those five flips so it's there are five
situations in which that happens and I
noticed I said exactly one heads because
if I said at least one heads then we
would have to take into the
circumstances where we have you know two
heads and then becomes more complicated
and we'll learn more about that when we
do combinations so what is the what what
are the chances of any one of these
possible outcomes well if we just look
at this one this there's a chance of 1/2
1/2 1/2 1/2 1/2 so it's 1/2 to the 5th
power which is equal to 1 over 32 and
you use the same logic each of these
this is 1 over 32 1 over 32 1 over 32 1
out of 32 and in general when I'm
flipping a fair coin five times in a row
there are going to be 32 possible
outcomes and each of these is just one
of the particular calm and we're
essentially saying out of the 32
outcomes
five satisfy the the event that we're
looking for exactly one heads out of
five flips so there are five that
satisfy it out of a total of thirty two
outcomes and so using that definition
only if we can say that all of the
outcomes are equally probable the
probability is five over thirty-two and
then you could say well let me make it a
little bit more complicated what is the
probability of not getting exactly one
head so here there is a lot of lot more
circumstances that satisfied so for
example let's let me draw out a couple
that would satisfy well you can get all
tails you get all tails but also if you
got two heads that would satisfy because
you didn't get exactly one head so this
would also satisfy it right and so you
might say well if we do it like this
it's really complicated but or you could
say well these these five over 32 are
the only outcomes that don't satisfy
that do not satisfy this condition so
the other the rest of the thirty-two of
what thirty two minus five is what
twenty seven the other twenty seven
outcomes will satisfy this so you can
say that this is equal to and this is a
common trick and a lot of probability
problems this is equal to one minus the
probability of a getting exactly one
heads out of five flips and that is
equal to you know one is the same thing
as 32 over 32
- what's the probability of this well we
figured it out it's five over thirty-two
and that equals twenty-seven over
thirty-two so that's just always
something to keep in mind sometimes when
you get a probability problem you it
seems difficult to solve that problem
but it's actually not that difficult to
solve the opposite problem so you say
well it's hard for me to exact to
directly figure out the probability of
not getting exactly one heads I'd have
to know combinations all of this
but this is the opposite of getting
exactly one heads and that's an easier
thing for me to figure out so if I can
figure out that probability all of the
other outcomes would satisfy the
opposite one hope I didn't confuse you
so anyway everything we've done so far
it's been dealing with coins and fair
coins and that's you know that's
interesting to a certain degree but
let's let's make it so that you know the
different outcomes have different
probabilities so let's let's do free
throw percentages because I think this
is something that we all you know if we
watch basketball or play at all any any
any any basketball we're familiar with
the idea so let's say that I and this is
not true I I only could wish let's say
that I have an 80% free-throw percentage
so that means every time I go to take a
free-throw there's a 80% chance there's
a basket and that there's a 20% chance
there's no basket and how is that how is
how does this come up with well you know
what we'll do more on statistics later
and they're really probability
statistics or opposite sides of the same
I guess coin you could say but someone
says okay you know out of the last 100
times Sal took free throws he's made 80
so in general he has an eighty percent
chance of making a particular free-throw
but it might not been hundred I might
have taken a thousand free throws and I
made eight hundred but that's where you
come up with the 80% from so that's fair
enough so we could call that you know so
the 80% is P and then a common notation
is the 20% is 1 minus P right if I have
an 80% chance of making the shot I have
a 20% chance of missing the shot right
so my question to you let's let's do
kind of the same examples we did with
the coins what's the probability of me
making I don't know three shots in a row
three baskets in a row or four three
free throws in a row let me say free
throws because it's my free throw
percentage not my overall shot well by
the same logic it's going to be equal I
would have to get eighty out the first
one I have to get right then the second
one I would have to get right I would
get
to get a basket and not you know there's
a 20% I'm it I have no basket and then
the third one I would have an 80% chance
right of getting a basket so this is I
didn't draw the rest of the tree right
it gets pretty broad but in general just
from the coin example you can just
multiply these probabilities right so
then you get so 80% is same thing is 0.8
so we get 0.8 to the third power and I
don't know what is that let me see
it is 0.8 times 0.8 times 0.8 is equal
to 50 1.2 or 0.5 1 to 51.2% is equal to
0.5 1/2 which is equal to 51.2%
so I have slightly better than ah even
odds of making three free throws in a
row which which is pretty good and as
you can see I don't have an exponent on
this cheapo windows provided calculator
I use so I have to apologize for that so
you might have to limit our exponent
size but anyway that should hopefully
well that's a little bit of a taste in
the next video I'll do a lot more
examples with the free throws in the
basket and we'll even a little bit about
conditional probability see you soon